über religiöse symbole wird hierzulande
seit jahren gestritten
nun wird die debatte grundsätzlich die
schweiz ist ein christlich geprägtes
land
mit dieser aussage hat zuletzt cvp
präsident graf ist das thema prominent
besetzt der philosoph michael
schmidt-salomon reagiert äußerst gereizt
wenn der untergang des christlichen
abendlandes heraufbeschworen wird
er ist nämlich der vorzeige freidenker
deutschlands vorstandssprecher der
giordano bruno stiftung einer
atheistischen denkfabrik und genau
deshalb haben wir ihn eingeladen
sie sind ja allergisch auf religiös
begründete werde herr schmidt salomon
können wir es ohne werte machen
natürlich brauchen wir werte des
zusammenlebens aber in einer modernen
gesellschaft beruht das ja auf der idee
des gesellschaftsvertrags und die besagt
ja dass die werte des zusammenlebens
nicht von einer höheren instanz also von
gott oder dem schicksal vorgegeben sind
sondern es dass diese werte des
zusammenlebens unter den gesellschafts
mitgliedern ausgehandelt werden
auf faire art und weise ja und das ist
eben ein anderer ansatz im säkularen
staates müssen wir auch unsere normen
säkulare gründen
das heißt sie dürfen eben nicht auf
religiösen überzeugungen ruhe weil viele
menschen diese überzeugung nicht teilen
und die werte müssen ja für alle gelten
also was ihm hier die andere
religionsauffassung haben oder keine
religion genau konfessionsfreie menschen
in der schweiz zwei wurde muss simon
cent oder muslime
was meinen sie mit gesellschaftsvertrag
das ist ja die grundidee eigentlich der
demokratie das haben in der aufklärung
gelernt dass diese werte nicht an sich
existieren und irgendwo gefunden werden
sondern dass wir diese wörter aushandeln
und deswegen verwandeln oder ändern die
sich mit der zeit die schweiz heute ist
ja deutlich anders als die schweiz der
50er jahre
sie haben erwähnt oder mit den
konfessionen die vorjahr 70er jahre noch
sehr prägend waren hohe prozentzahl von
menschen die in den christlichen kirchen
noch mitglied waren
heute etwas weniger vielleicht so um die
70 prozent uns gehört gleichwohl diese
figur diese bemerkung des christlich
geprägten landes
wir hören uns noch kurz an wie das
klingt von gelb ist oder dem präsidenten
der christlichdemokratischen volkspartei
der schweiz in der sendung arena lässt
ihn nicht vom land sondern redet vom
nachricht geprägt also sie haben dass
microsoft deutschland zum beispiel im
blick mainz vorbereitet die schweiz ist
ein christliches land dazu sollten wir
widerstehen und wir sollten klar machen
dass wir bereit sind dieses erbe zu
verteilen richtig dass ich genug sagte
cvp präsident mehr hans c im parteinamen
schwitzig rechtliches land in dem sinn
dass rechtlich gebirgsland ist aber
stets hatten säkularer staat und das ist
ebenfalls entscheidend es gehört zu der
schweiz wo sie verträge von einem
säkularen staat habe aber tradition
diesem land die nicht ganz klar ist aber
wenn sie sage mal klingt doch
nachvollziehbar klingt ganz ausgewogen
naja wenn er sich auf die vergangenheit
bezieht hatte ja auch recht
also die schweiz war eindeutig
christlich geprägt und hier starken von
zwingli und von kalin das hat sich aber
verändert und das ist auch gut so dass
sich das verändert hat denn weder calvin
noch noch zwingel waren jetzt vertreter
der rechte des individuums der
meinungsfreiheit der forschungsfreiheit
der kunstfreiheit all diese werte waren
bei ihnen ja gar nicht verankert das
gegenteil war leider der fall
wir hatten auch in der schweiz leider so
form von religiösen diktaturen
kontaktiert die show unterton sonst
sondern hören aber wenn von christlichen
werten die rede ist jetzt möchte ich
noch mal wissen wie würden sie die
definieren
das ist natürlich schwierig also für
jemand der evangelikal ausgerichtet ist
erzählt ja nur das evangelium da kann
man natürlich nachlesen was sind die
werte die in diesen heiligen schriften
stehen und da wird man natürlich nicht
die universellen menschenrechte finden
logischerweise denn diese werte sind ja
formuliert morgen zu einem zeitpunkt
anderen zivilisatorischen stufe der
menschheit also man kann das jesus ja
nun wahrlich nicht
werfen aber auch mohammed nicht aber
nicht wie jetzt bei der bibel sehr
häufig sagt jesus es sind nur wenige
auserwählte und für die wenigen die
auserwählt sind für die wartet das
himmelreich aber für die allermeisten
menschen auf der erde droht quasi das
dass das ewige flammenmeer an der
menschensohn wird seine engel aus senden
und die bösen in den ofen schieben wo
das feuer ewig brennt das ist natürlich
nicht eine keine demokratische tolerante
denkungsart normal diese höhlen figuren
natürlich auch erklärt einfach um den
ernst die ernsthaftigkeit der
entscheidung aber schauen sie sich an
wie das neue testament endet das wird
heute nicht mehr so stark geprägt wie
gepredigt wie vor dem krieg aber die
offenbarung des johannes ist ein
unfassbar sadistisches buch wenn man so
wörtlich liegen mannswörth ist ist es ja
lange gelesen worden
wir haben aber natürlich jetzt eine von
constantini sieht an westliche werte zum
beispiel wie sagt nächstenliebe oder das
sind also wichtigste gebot wenn ihre
zeit gehört wurde er sagte ja du
solltest deinen nächsten lieben gott
lieben ja liebe deinen nächsten wie dich
selbst nur sind es eben keine
christlichen werte die nächstenliebe
finden wir in allen kulturen
nächstenliebe war nie das problem auch
solidarität all solidarität also es egal
welche kultur wir uns anschauen
nächstenliebe wird in jeder kultur
gepredigt und auch oft praktiziert das
problem in der menschlichen geschichte
war nie die nächstenliebe sondern der
fernsten hats ja und da können wir
leider feststellen je stärker dieser
gruppen zusammenhang in den vordergrund
gerückt wurde du musst deinen nächsten
lieben
umso mehr wurden die fremden als
feindliche gehasst damit würden sie aber
auch unterscheiden was bei den
religionsgründer gehabt wurden was dann
kirchen oder religionsgemeinschaften
daraus machen sind zwei branchen
na ja weil es war ja von anfang an so
wenn wir uns die heiligen schriften
anschauen dann finden sie wenig toleranz
bei jesus gegenüber den menschen die
andere glaubensüberzeugungen
in der warmherzigen es nur für die leute
die man im eigenen glauben angehören
überzeugt der christen würden die nets
haben jesus war friedliebend tolerant
und so weiter aber man fragt heißt das
aber rechnet esstische werte definiert
genau und wir müssen ja auch
feststellung das ist ja auch gut so das
ist eine entwicklung in der exegese
gegeben hat gerade hier in mitteleuropa
das sieht in anderen teilen der welt
leider deutlich anders aus schriften
dann ihn den kontext gestellt da sie
haben es durch heute sehr viele sehr
liberale christen und auch theologen die
säkular denken die einen andersdenkenden
andersgläubigen oder ungläubigen nicht
die gleichen rechte absprechen
nun ist es eine neue entwicklung in der
in der geschichte und für ein analytisch
denken philosophen wie mich ist es
manchmal schwierig wie gehen dann diese
theologen mit texten um wenn sie eine
passage aus der bibel haben und zehn
theologen werden sie zehn völlig
unterschiedliche interpretationen dazu
finden also offenkundig nicht nur die
wege des herrn unergründlich sondern
auch die wege der damen und herren die
sich mit ihm beschäftigen
aber man muss auch sehen einerseits eine
gewisse pluralität ja auch ist sie aus
erfrischend natürlich strecken wird oder
einzelne texte sie sind ja nicht jetzt
der theologe und nicht der spezialist
ich wollte das einfach mal hören wie sie
das definieren würden wie haben sie
eingeladen weil sie eben die grenzen der
toleranz anmahnen wir kommen dazu zuvor
will ich ganz kurz ein fragebogen weil
wir von christlichen symbol ausgehen mit
ihn ausfüllen kurz die fixe in
klassenzimmern ja oder nein nein nein
kirchlich verantwortete
religionsunterricht in öffentlichen
schulen sehr viel besser wäre ein
allgemeiner unterricht für alle denn wir
sollten die kinder nicht religiös ghetto
visieren als auch dann ein kreuz an
einer halskette
das ist jedem frei überlassen
regionsweit dass es ein menschenrecht
wir müssen uns müssen wir kämpfen hier
ja geht für kreuze auf bergen ich bin
nicht der meinung dass man sie absagen
muss aber ich denke man sollte keine
neuen kreuzer aufstellen dringend marie
ein ja oder nein nein
okay was heißt jetzt dass bei den
symbolen davos öffentlich wird da wo das
interesse aller betroffenen ist da ist
ein klares nein
ja ist es ja so eltern haben natürlich
das recht ihre kinder auf der basis
ihrer jeweiligen präferenzen zu erziehen
religiöse präferenzen politische
präferenzen das ist ja gar nicht anders
möglich
die frage ist ob der staat geschlossen
zu einem kumpanen werden darf der
weltanschaulichen verengung ich meine
hier kinder haben ein recht auf
möglichst vorurteilsfrei bildung
das heißt sie sollten eben nicht
zusätzlich auch noch vom staat in eine
bestimmte richtung gelenkt werden
sondern sie sollten das wissen bekommen
das ihnen dann später die chance bietet
dass sie selbst kritisch reflektieren
können und ihre eigene sicht der welt
entwickeln das wäre diese säkulare staat
denn auch genau cvp präsident gerhard
pfister angemahnt hat genau
und hier ist eben die frage wo setzt man
die prioritäten und warum haben wir
jetzt eine wertedebatte wo dieses
christliche jahren wieder angemahnt
werden
das ist etwas was man bei vielen
neokonservativen auch bei
rechtspopulisten feststellt man versucht
wissen was das christentum das sich
weitgehend säkularisierten wieder
aufzurüsten
als ein instrument zur verhinderung der
sogenannten islamisierung wer versucht
das nun das ist etwas was wir bei den
bei dieser internationalen der
nationalisten feststellen können das ist
eine entwicklung die wir weltweit sehen
von moskau bis nach washington
ja es wird eben verrührt die betonung
einer besonderen nationalen identität
verbunden mit sogenannten christlichen
werten
man versucht das zusammenzufassen als
ein bollwerk damit es nicht zur
gesellschaftlichen veränderungen kommt
und die drohkulisse aufgebaut wird ist
natürlich der islam an sagt eben die
islamisierung dass es ein klares ziel
von bestimmten gruppierung im islam das
stimmt auch das stimmt auch
aber natürlich ist es kein gutes
gegenmittel ja eine christianisierung an
die stelle der islamisierung zu rücken
denn wir haben doch diese diese werte
des säkularen rechtsstaat r kämpft gegen
den druck der kirchen und auch dieser
christlichen konfessionen sie
wahrscheinlich sagen werte wie freiheit
oder gleichheit freiheit christliche
werte zu recht werte der aufklärung sind
werte der aufklärung haben auch eine
lange tradition
wir können ja eigentlich zurückgehen
auch bei der idee des
gesellschaftsvertrags bis zu epikur vor
2300 jahren
interessanterweise hat sich epikur in
der geschichte durchgesetzt
jefferson hat hat die amerikanische
unabhängigkeitserklärung die die
präambel gewissermaßen bei epicor
abgeschrieben und auch unser ganzes
heutige welt heutiges weltbild
eigentlich auf diesen ideen von epikur
denn so signatur mystische welt
keinerlei spuren des christentums heute
das stimmt nicht wir haben natürlich
spuren des christentums aber es ist so
dass diese traditionellen christlichen
werte zum großen teil überwunden worden
sind das sind ja auch tatsächlich eben
werte die die andersdenkenden nicht
respektiert wenn ich habe hier immer ein
buch eine kurze geschichte der toleranz
geschrieben also es gibt einen
unglaublichen einbruch der toleranz und
der religiösen toleranz mit der
machtübernahme des christentums das
vergessen viele wenn man sich die
geschichte anschaut die frühen christen
haben ja gewütet wie die taliban
der artikel so zu sagen haben ein
großteil der literatur vernichtet die es
damals gab und das führte auch zum
großen kulturellen einbruch und hier
haben es letztlich sogar den muslimen
zum großen teil zu sprechen von christen
nach der konstant dänischen wende
maristen testen wurden ja mehrheitlich
verfolgt richtig wir haben eine
veränderung natürlich dass das des
christentums am anfang ist das
christentum eine jüdische weltuntergangs
sektor aber wir sind inzwischen im
heutigen london dabei den grenzen der
toleranz
jetzt in sie sagen auch wenn die
christen wird jetzt so wie sie es
interpretieren nicht mehr diese prägung
haben sie sagen die aufklärung wenn es
sich die verstand bringen uns die
entscheidenden werte für die heutige
offene gesellschaft warum stoßen jetzt
hier an grenzen warum machen sie ein
buch die grenzen der toleranz warum wir
die offene gesellschaft verteidigen
müssen
naja es ist ja offenkundig dass die
offenen gesellschaft im moment bedroht
ist
zum einen tatsächlich durch islamisten
es gibt einen islamischen faschismus
deine bedrohung weltweit darstellt muss
man natürlich unterscheiden es gibt auch
in islamischen humanismus der die offene
gesellschaft unterstützen würde aber es
gibt eben diese eine bedrohung
und es gibt eben eine andere bedrohung
das sind diese rechtspopulisten die
christlichen abendland retter die
gewissermaßen auch die das rad der
geschichte zurückdrehen wollen und
letztlich drei moderne dogmen an die
stelle moderner individueller
freiheitsrechte auf der einen seite bei
faschismus bin ich immer sehr vorsichtig
leben für muslime zum beispiel ich finde
das kam sehr verletzend sein
na gut aber wir müssen uns anschauen was
bedeuten die begriffe und der punkt ist
ja dass der die islamisierung des islams
ist ein produkt des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts so vorher nicht gegeben sie
in der natur ische judenhass
radikalisierung verschärfungen als ein
teil
ja und da muss man sehen es gab eben
starke verbindung der nazis der
nationalsozialisten zu führenden
vertretern des damaligen islam der
großmufti von jerusalem ist ja geflohen
nach berlin lebte da im avisierten haus
bekam sehr viel geld von den nazis und
tat seinen eliminator ischen judenhass
über ein nazi propaganda sind in die
ganze welt posaunt und dadurch verändert
sich tatsächlich die wahrnehmung des
juden in der islamischen welt das mich
danach ist speziell das habe ich auch an
habe ich auch beschrieben in denen das
heißt wir müssen sehr genau mit diesen
begriffen umgehen ich halte auch nichts
davon
diesen faschismus vorwurf diese nazi
keule zu benutzen wir müssen sehr genau
hinschauen wo ist dieser begriff
rechtfertigt und wo nicht das haben wir
diskutiert hier mit abdel samad der
diese richte sich zum beispiel für
jährlich das können jetzt hier in dieser
ausführlichkeit nicht leisten bisher
noch die andere seite angetönt können
sie mal beispiele machen jetzt auch von
sie nennen das fundamentalistisch
christlicher seite wer wird denn die
offene gesellschaft wo wird die wirklich
so unter beschuss genommen
wir haben die wahlen in den usa gehabt
viele haben sich hier konzentriert auf
ein schwamm aber eigentlich ist sind die
leute hinter ihm das eigentliche problem
denn jetzt regiert oder ab dem nächsten
jahr regiert die tea party in amerika
und da haben sie natürlich bestimmte
formen von von von intoleranz von
abgrenzung gegenüber den anderen die
hoch problematisch sondern es gibt einen
ich bin ja in ein scharfer kritiker
dieses dieser faschistoiden strömung des
islams aber ich bin kein anti muslim ist
und genau das findet man aber natürlich
nicht nur in amerika sondern findet in
russland man findet es in deutschland
man findet auch in der schweiz dass
viele menschen diese berechtigte kritik
an diesen nicht aufgeklärten varianten
des islams nutzen um unter diesem
deckmantel einer aufgeklärten islam
kritik letztlich an die aufklärerische
ziele zu fördern beispiele hier bei uns
wir schauen sie sich manche schon einen
der svp an
schauen sie sich manche dinge an die bei
kita in deutschland oder bei der afg
diskutiert werden
hier wird die religionsfreiheit wirklich
zurückgefahren und tatsächlich wird
einen hass auf muslime geschürt der
höchsten höchsten maßen problematisches
ja aber man kann es aber auch in anderen
dingen feststellen also beispielsweise
in der afg ist ist diese gruppe der
christlich-fundamentalistischen
lebensschutz sehr stark verankert
führende personen dieser partei
kritisieren den islamischen
fundamentalismus gehören aber letztlich
einen christlichen fundamentalismus an
und diese gruppierung versuchen
gewissermaßen mit dieser bedrohung des
islams letztlich werte aus den 50er
jahren wieder hoffähig zu machen in
diesen westlichen demokratien und wir
sollten froh sein dass wir nicht mehr
den fünfziger jahren leben sondern diese
freiheitsrechte beispielsweise
gleichberechtigung von homosexuellen
das müssen wir verteidigen denn diese
werte geraten unter druck
gerade durch diese rechtspopulistischen
gruppierung also das wäre ein konkretes
beispiel welche werte sind ihre werte
welche werte würden sie jetzt vorrücken
also ich habe in dem buch beschrieben
dass die offene gesellschaft durch vier
fundamentale prinzipien geprägt ist
nämlich durch freiheit gleichheit durch
individualität und säkularität also das
sind die vier werte oder vier prinzipien
die wir unbedingt verteidigen müssen
individuelle freiheit gegen staatlichen
paternalismus das ist etwas was wir
verteidigen müssen auch den wert der
gleichheit der gleichbehandlung aller
menschen
das ist etwas was man in einer offenen
gesellschaft akzeptieren muss dass alle
menschen gleichberechtigt sind deswegen
haben wir diskriminierungsverbote in
unserer verfassung
das sind dinge die wieder zurückgefahren
werden sollen
und natürlich eben auch dass die offene
gesellschaft geht vom individuum aus und
nicht von kollektiven nicht von
religionsgemeinschaften und auch nicht
von von sitten und stämmen und ethnien
oder auch nicht in der familie
wir haben bei muslimischen familien sehr
häufig das große problem dass die
individuen gerade die jüngeren die
kinder und jugendlichen all die
freiheiten die in die offene
gesellschaft bietet gar nicht nutzen
können weil sie unter so starker
familiärer kontrolle stehen
da gibt es bislang keine wirklich
vernünftigen gegenmaßnahmen und die
gegenmaßnahmen die brauchen wir dringend
wir brauchen bessere bildung sie finden
diese vier kriegt den dringen
nachvollziehbar aber was heißt sekula
säkular heißt dass beispielsweise der
startklar machen muss dass die
religionen nicht über dem gesetz stehen
sie müssen sich den gesetzen unterordnen
und das ist sehr häufig eben nicht
passiert wenn man sich beispielsweise
die deutsche das deutsche beschneidung
gesetz anschaut stellt man fest dass
hier die rechte von kindern und gerade
diesmal von von jungen in grober weise
missachtet worden sind weil man
tatsächlich den religionen so billig
dass sie sich gewissermaßen über die
gesetze stellen können und das dürfen
wir nicht machen denn wir müssen das
profil einer offenen gesellschaft
stärken
da ziehen sie nie klar ganz klare linie
ich bin aber auch über begriffe wie
freiheits androhungen oder abschreckung
durch freiheit gestorben also wir haben
schon die grenzen der toleranz und jetzt
noch freiheits androhungen es klingt
nach abwehrschlacht ja ich bin wir haben
eine ganz andere form von
abschreckungspolitik in den letzten
monaten gesehen stacheldrahtzäune
tränengas unwürdige unterbringung von
flüchtlingen um sie abzuschrecken
hinzukommen das sind keine massnahmen
einer offenen gesellschaft sondern einer
geschlossenen gesellschaft darf auch
eine offene gesellschaft geschlossen
leute abschrecken die diese werte der
freiheit der gleichheit der sexualität
und individualität nicht teilen
ich denke schon aber man darf das eben
nur mit mit den methoden machen die
diese prinzipien nicht selbst verletzen
also wir können natürlich darauf an so
zivilisierten methoden genau also wir
müssen einfach klarmachen dass sich die
religionen hier dem gesetz unterordnen
müssen dass männer und frauen
gleichberechtigt sind
hetero homo und transsexuelle
gleichberechtigt sind und dass die
verehrung des propheten mohammed oder
auch des christlichen messias ansicht ja
keinen höheren zivilgesellschaftlichen
anspruch hat als etwa die verehrung von
borussia dortmund von monty python oder
von dolly buster
das müssen wir klar machen dass wir eben
in einer wirklich säkularen gesellschaft
sind und wir müssen für diese werte auch
ein stehen also eine der gründe warum
ich das buch geschrieben habe war eine
kleine meldung
als der präsident des iran
hermann italien besucht hat hat man aus
respekt vor seiner religion in diesem
gottes startet jemand interessiert ja
noch in erinnerung jahr hat man die
nackten staaten auf dem capitol verhüllt
ja und das darf eben nicht passieren
denn hier müsse irgendwann auch
hingenommen
wir sollten eben wir sollten wirklich
unsere werte nicht schamhaft verhüllen
sollten uns stattdessen sehr bewusster
zu bekennen denn freiheit gleichheit
säkularität im individual es sind keine
werte und die man sich schämen müsste
sondern das sind die die bedeutendsten
früchte und wichtigsten motoren des
zivilisatorischen fortschritt unserer
spezies und dafür müssen wir eintreten
und unsere politiker müssen auch dafür
eintreten
sie dürfen nicht diese rückgratlosen
peaceman politik gegenüber
rücksichtslosen despoten zeigen
darüber kann ich mich tatsächlich
auffallend ich reg mich nicht über die
formel vom christlichen abendland auf
aber ich rege mich darüber auf dass
jemand wie greifbar wie der in saudi
arabien zu zehn jahren haft und 1000
peitschenhieben verurteilt worden ist
weil er für die menschenrechte
eingetreten ist und für den säkularen
staat dass wir zwar symbolisch sagen der
muss frei kommen aber keine sanktionen
gegen dieses land verhängen im gegenteil
deutschland hat jetzt die
rüstungsexporte nach saudi arabien
verdreifacht und das halte ich wirklich
für unwürdig in einer offenen also man
merkt wie komplex verletzt sie da
unterwegs sind wir jetzt wirklich ins
ins feuer kommen wenn es um die
verteidigung neben ver grenzen der
toleranz um die verteidigung oder
offenen gesetzes in wirklich ein
anliegen spürt man was haben sie denn
ihren kritikern ich habe hier michael
rüegg eine philosophie in st gallen
lebte sagte diese einheitliche humane
welt kultur die sie vertreten würde ihn
schon an die sowjetunion oder an die
volksrepublik china erinnern und sie
wäre
hände eine gesinnungs diktatur das ist
ja unsinn
man muss sagen dass das der humanismus
verpönt war in beiden systemen sowohl in
china als auch in der sowjetunion
aber darum geht es gar nicht es geht gar
nicht darum dass wir jetzt irgendwelche
westlichen werte anderen kulturen
überstülpen sondern dass uns bewusst
wird dass diese welt kultur also das
weltkulturerbe humanismus und aufklärung
kein exklusiver besitz des westens es
denn daran haben menschen aller kulturen
gearbeitet und aller kontinente und
aller zeiten
ich gehe auch in dem buch darauf ein
dass in einer gewissen zeit phase vom
neunten bis zwölften jahrhundert diese
sogenannten westlichen werte sehr viel
eher östliche werte waren weil sie in
muslimischen kultur raum er beheimatet
waren als im christlichen europa
insofern könnte herr pfister auch sagen
dass wir ein muslimisches land sind ja
weil wir letztlich diese werte des
säkularen staats geerbt haben aus diesen
muslimischen kultur um weil die nämlich
diese alten heidnischen schriften der
schlussmann wieder erhalten haben was so
wie sie sagen nachvollziehbar ist heute
schon eine provokation oder wenn sie so
zu formulieren
noch ein anderer einwurf thomas
hürlimann ein schweizer schriftsteller
sagt vor kurzem im tages anzeiger
wir hatten weiter und da diese glaubens
bereitschaft einen inhalt haben muss
formiert sich die gesellschaft in einer
sekte die sich selbst überwacht und
terrorisiert der neue katechismus heißt
erstes gebot du sollst den abfall
trennen zweites gebot du sollst dich
vegan ernähren
sie schmunzeln schon dreht das gebot du
sollst alles durch ländern wird das
gebot du sollst so tolerant sein wie
glory im neuesten buch also wir menschen
neigen natürlich dazu bestimmte
verhaltensweisen zu dokumentieren und
deswegen müssen wir immer kritisch
rational alles hinterfragen also das ja
wenn ich einen kategorischen imperativ
aber dann ist es doch der dass wir daran
arbeiten müssen falsche ideen sterben zu
lassen bevor menschen für falsche ideen
sterben müssen
wir müssen unser denken permanent
überprüfen und
ändern ja und wir müssen uns daran
gewöhnen dass die welt permanent im
fluss ist und ab sie haben keine angst
dass wir da in so eine eben gesinnungs
diktatur sah nach einer seltsamen
überwachungs geschichte genommen
wir müssen wenn so etwas aufkommt und es
ist ja nicht komplett falsch was da
geschrieben wurde
dann müssen wir eben kritisch
hinterfragen na und das große problem
dass natürlich entsteht auch durch
facebook und co ist der konfirmation bei
ist dass wir gewissermaßen nur bei denen
nach argumenten suchen die ohnehin
unserer meinung sind es eben müssen wir
trainieren und die gegenargumente zu
unserer positionen anzuschauen ja das
ist die grundlage meiner evolutionär
realistischen philosophie aber auch die
grundlage des kritischen rationalismus
ich muss schauen wer hat möglicherweise
bessere argumente als ich denn es ist ja
nicht notwendigerweise so dass ich ihm
recht ganz kurz zum schluss er
möglicherweise sind sie nicht dem recht
seelen ort könnte es ganz kurz zum
schluss ja mia ihre werte jetzt noch
erläutert könnte es ein brückenschlag
geben mit religiösen werten
absolut also ich bin ja auf der seite
der liberalen muslime und der liberalen
christen habe ich auch ein buch
geschrieben eigentlich bräuchten wir so
das motto humanisten aller konfessionen
vereinigt euch ja denn die
entscheidenden unterschiede bestehen da
nicht zwischen gläubigen und
nichtgläubigen zwischen christen und
muslimen sondern zwischen menschen die
einen weltoffenen zugang haben
die sie auch korrigieren lassen und
denen die einen dogmatischen zugang zur
welt haben ja und da müssen wir die
richtigen koalition schließen dass diese
menschen die kritische rational auch mit
religion umgehen dass die mit denen
zusammenarbeiten die die religion für
sich selbst schon überwunden haben sie
sind gesprächsbereit denke ich aber es
weitergeht herzlichen dank für die
schöne zahlungen in der sternstunde
philosophie unterhält sich jetzt gleich
meine kollegin barbara bleisch mit dem
renommierten französischen philosophen
alain badiou darüber was eine
gesellschaft zusammenhält
auch weltweit ob allein radio das wohl
anders sieht mit den wirten sehen sie
selbst
[Musik]